la création de geneviève mangeard et
artistes andrésienne ses douze collage
fantaisistes et singulier présentée dans
la galerie des passions d'andrésy
[Musique]
vous avez là une porte de prison qui
s'ouvre avec une licorne denis
qu'exprime le rêve dans les nuages et
les les tableaux sont vides à
l'intérieur mais bon et puis l'heure le
ticket levier trop grosse et c'est une
sorte d'allégorie comme ça de symboles
inc
[Musique]
un découpage fruit d'un travail amorcé
en 2020 quelques assemblage plus tard
l'exposition est née geneviève a dû
toutefois y ajouter une pincée de touche
personnelle d'où le nom de l'exposition
collage encre et pastels dans cette
thématique là de l'écolage oui
effectivement parfois il ya une
complémentarité de avec pastel avec
parfois un peu de peinture d'acrylique
de ça dépend en fait la fin justifie les
moyens
comme thème récurrent les oiseaux
j'habite dans un endroit où j'ai la
chance d'être au dessus de la scène et
de voir le matin comme le soir volé les
oiseaux alors je ne sais pas si ça eu
une influence peut-être sais pas mais
surtout l'artiste s'est laissé porter
par son inspiration
moi ya pas de sens
obligé où
chacun y voit ce qu'il veut et ça c'est
la liberté de pouvoir
vivre regarder quelque chose comme on a
envie de regarder ça c'est très
important dans la galerie se trouve
aussi une partie d'anciennes création de
l'artiste andrésienne l'exposition est
en accès libre du mercredi au dimanche
de 10 heures à 19 heures et jusqu'au 27
février